notice any similarities about these East
Asian women on screen
they all have what is referred to as the
Asian hair Street it's a shortcut used
by Hollywood and the comic book world to
signal that a character is rebellious or
edge there are a lot of examples back in
2014 the tumblr blog writing with color
found 12 and there have been more since
and for the most part it's just a boring
racist trope oh god they're looks so
good
the overwhelming amount of Asian girls
with purple hair streaks it's just like
kind of ridiculous this is an e sheet in
2017 she tweeted about the trend and
there were thousands of retweets it's
just like a symptom of altogether the
non diversity of Hollywood and popular
media representations of Asians in
American popular culture are very
shallow and so and so if you only have a
few Asians ever appearing then if you
have something like streaks and of
course it's going to take on a
significance of bad or good it wouldn't
happen with a white character because
there's so many quite characters can
examine the roles and stereotypes of
Asian women in film and TV in a 1988
documentary and revisited the topic in
2011 23 years later she didn't find that
much had changed the same archetype
still exists today
the most common representation of Asian
women were as docile sex objects get a
massage from Chinese girl people oh I
got a tow oh let me get her in a black
Poorna pink baby or a kind of sinister
dragon lady types who would stab you in
the back dragon lady were sometimes sexy
too yeah
or as completely fascinated or sort of
honorary white characters the the
resonated ones that I mentioned usually
helping the white folks for being a foil
to the white folks in the film there's
sidekick it's been an issue that's gone
through 50 years and it never really has
gotten a whole lot better some is a
fantastic cook you want any better Thai
food in Bangkok
what's help a new dog mr. hobby mainly
there were just no central characters so
how do we solve the problem it starts by
giving Asian Americans control of their
own narrative if you give Asian
Americans the ability to do the
representation to write the story it
will come out completely different from
the usual stereotypes there was one
person who was the lead and that was in
the silent film era in the early talkies
and that was Anna May Wong although she
played mostly dragon ladies she was in
some B movies that she had a voice in
producing she was a central character
she was not a dragon lady issues not a
Madame Butterfly she was usually like an
adventuresome doctor or some business
person or something like that
and what we want is just somebody cruza
a complicated human being the way we
know ourselves to be we could deal with
the dragon ladies and the butterflies we
had lots of other things they're cute in
the 100 top films of 2017 65 films did
not have a single female Asian speaking
character by comparison white females
are only missing from seven films more
East Asian women are needed on screen
and there needs to be more diverse
characters they don't need to be over
sexualized maybe some of them are coming
of age maybe some of them are leaves and
if they're rebellious they don't need
streaks in their hair that's really
birth you should rinse
[Music]
I can hear anything you're saying